je me trouve actuellement dans la
station balnéaire du touquet et si je
porte un masque alors que je suis en
extérieur bien ce n'est pas par plaisir
mais bien parce que ce dernier est à
nouveau obligatoire dans les rues du
centre ville une décision du maire qui
souhaite se prémunir d'une cinquième
vague près de vingt mille nouveaux cas
sont en effet détecté par jour en france
dans le pas de calais le taux
d'incidence atteint 102 7 nouveaux cas
pour 100000 habitants selon la
préfecture soit deux fois plus qu'il ya
un mois une augmentation conséquente qui
a poussé le maire du touquet a décrété
le retour du masque en extérieur une
décision reçu de façon mitigée par les
habitants écoutez c'est toujours le même
rituel on recommence on se demande quand
est-ce que ça va se finir
et ça commence à peser on a pris ça ce
matin en allant au marché on n'a pas
compris parce qu'on s'est dit dans la
rue en extérieur on sait qu'à pas de
souci donc on s'est dit une fois de plus
passé le touquet et le microcosme du
touquet qu impose des règles bien à eux
donc étant touquettois je l'admets mais
c'est un peu too much c'est si je peux
moi je trouve ça plutôt bien parce que
je trouvais que ça a été des faits trop
rapidement personnellement et vu qu'il
ya quand même pas mal de monde je trouve
que c'est plutôt pas mal le retour du
masque en extérieur une mesure qui
concerne également emmanuel macron en
villégiature ce week end au touquet le
président qui était en visite dans
l'aisne et dans le nord ce vendredi sur
les terres de xavier bertrand à cinq
mois des présidentielles le chef de
l'état a annoncé deux nouvelles aides
financières pour la région à hauteur de
100 millions d'euros une enveloppe
importante qui pourrait lui permettre de
marcher sur les plates-bandes de son
rival républicain et donc on voit bien
l'enjeu dépasse mutuelle
c'est l'intérêt de la france et
l'intérêt des français va pas être
simple et tout le monde sent bien de
cette victoire est à la portée de votre
vin fap pour nous seulement
mais parce que je pense que ce sont les
solutions de la droite républicaine et
une droite populaire ils sont à même de
la fois redresser notre pays il
rassemble et les poussettes on a
sacrément devant être rassemblées le
président de la république en
déplacement ce lundi à amiens dans sa
ville natale c'est là également qui
avait été annoncé en 2016 le lancement
de son mouvement en marche un retour aux
sources dans une région présidée par
l'un de ses plus sérieux challenger au
scrutin d'avril prochain